hey rich how are you doing good man
what's shaking what are you for oh man
big fan reading all your books um
yeah so i currently own i started
business but a year and a half ago
and i work with
fitness businesses across the country
and we're doing about 40 000 a month
right now about a year and a half in
and uh
we're just kind of plateaued there
except we stayed there the last few
months
you know we have like nearly 100
retention of our clients hold on
turn my lights on here but uh
and i'm just not really sure what to do
next like i'm considering you know
hiring sales guys but i just don't know
if that's the move or not
so sorry you're doing 40 grand a month
and what problem do you solve your
fitness products uh we get so we work
with gym owners and we bring people into
their business
so you get clients for jib so you're
basically marketing your marketing
essentially yeah yeah it's a software
the sas products combined with when we
run their facebook ads yeah well that
should be pretty scalable because i mean
there's a lot of gyms out there
it's a white label sass product i don't
know if that matters but
why isn't it growing like why do you
think it's not moving up
i mean
a month in sales right our product is
unbelievable we have an unbelievable
amazing product
but we just have trouble
i think i i think we're in the process
of like getting that hockey stick effect
right and going to the next level and i
think the next level is to build a sales
team and i was and i'm assuming you had
a sales team at your company in the past
so i'll i'll um you know i'll tell you a
dirty little secret you don't need a
a big or a great sales team if you have
a fantastic product it should sell
itself
yeah
so
so why are like are you approaching gyms
like how are you getting to them
um i have a database of 7000 gyms and i
cold call them when i get time but it's
i'm getting
i try to really prioritize my service so
every single client gets the same exact
product
over and over so it's really
replicatable
but i'm just running into issues with uh
um you know continuing to do sales while
while still making sure that we're
delivering a consistency like have you
gotten gotten into big chains like la
fitness good life goals
we have a couple franchises that we work
with but honestly the bet the gyms that
are a better fit are like crossfit gyms
boutique studio gyms well you're never
going to get the scalability that way
right because i mean like you want you
want to get into a big chain so you're
doing all of the la fitness chains
around you know i mean i don't know
there's another guy that's scalable that
way right there's another guy on my
space that does just the agency and he
he doesn't work with franchises and he
does over 30 million a year so i think i
think he's doing pretty well
okay well
how big is the um like what's the market
cap for the boutique places
oh it's big like like the guy that's
doing 30 million he only has like eight
percent of the market which is still a
big piece of the market so what's he
doing differently than you
uh he's been in the business longer and
they have how much excel
he's been in business for five years
i've been in for a year and a half okay
so what else does he do difference you
know aside from the time frame
um he has a good
he has good marketing but honestly his
product sucks
it works crap product you have a better
product but his marketing is better
exactly so it's but i mean i like
i
like if i have a better product i need
to get it out there my market is a bit
jaded too like they've all had a bad
experience with a marketing company like
everyone every business owner has so i
have to break through that barrier so
that's why we have a performance-based
model but still people it's very hard to
get people to pay attention so we have
do you have a freemium model
um
we do we
we've talked about doing that but um
because it means very high that way you
know you can prove it
20 000 ltv what's that each client on
average between 15 and 15 and 20 000 ltv
in their first year okay so
for those of you watching that don't
know what we're talking about because
we're kind of getting into some sort of
like acronyms and code words and stuff
like that
um
you know it's it's like really really
important to like get all this stuff
like hashed out
right
um the one thing that really bothers me
though is that you're talking about the
other
uh guy who has a crap product but he's
doing 30 million dollars a year
um
i hate to tell you this dude like you
might think that his product is crap but
it's selling
it's not it's not crap i just know i
know i know what we do is better but
it's okay but i'm like the market has
decided that his business is better than
your business so absolutely i'm going to
come back to you again with well why
aren't you growing at that rate like why
are you stagnated
i think it's i think it's sales i think
we need to build a sales team because
we're not we're like all of our
businesses word of mouth as of right now
how is the other guy selling how's the
30 million dollar year guy selling he
has a large sales team right he runs ads
he spends 100 000 a month on ads and
scales that way
so he's targeting
the owners of crossfits and boutique
gems yes exactly is there an area that
that he doesn't touch like dojos or like
something else that you might be able to
like
r d and apply the uh
same techniques over the only the only
businesses that that we can help
effectively are businesses that can do
group fitness at this time
groups okay well they have group
training in dojos
yeah they do they'll do they'll do group
fitness yeah but he still he still
touches them too where do you live like
in the states or in canada i just moved
to miami from uh from boston okay the
state's pretty open for stuff like that
like the gyms are open they're not like
checking for vaccine passports okay so
you're in the right place so that's good
well
you know what r d stands for
research and development rip off and
duplicate nice
yeah so
i mean you found a competitor that you
think has a
inferior product
that's selling in a superior way
he's he's got some systems in place that
you can probably learn from
i'm sure there's also other businesses
out there because you're saying the
market cap is huge
that have a lot more market share that
you know than you do so i mean like if
your product is
like if your sas code is
superior to what they're offering
you should have no issues whatsoever
taking a look at what their business
model is r d in that and then kind of
plug it into your business and then just
scaling it up right yeah
that's what i'm trying that's what i'm
trying to do but that would be that
would be the smart way to scale it up
quickly is just r d it and it's not
research and development it's rip off
and duplicate right that is more so what
we're doing but but i would say but like
how much
how much should i like as i'm as i'm
ripping off and duplicating right how
much like like i find that i'm making
small changes in areas where i think
that they're lacking
do i say through that just rip it off
you know this this all like comes back
to what i was talking about earlier
where like as an entrepreneur you have
to be a good problem solver so you have
a problem you know the industry like you
know like the back your hand i can't
give you the you know the cheat codes to
success on this you know step by step
you're going to have to be good at
solving that problem right yeah yeah i
mean i can just offer a little bit of
you know like fuel the juices sort of
thing like okay well i've never really
thought about you know like ripoff and
duplicate because i think it's research
and development
right yeah and that's all that's all i'm
looking for you know and that's it i saw
this saw the link and i'm like let's
jump on there's nothing there's nothing
new generally to invent there's not a
lot of new business ideas out there
they're all either a marriage of two
existing businesses two or three or more
or
something that was you know like
rehashed or just done better than
somebody else yeah um you know timing's
super important i mean
yeah gyms are really struggling right
now like i know gyms here are really
struggling because we've got passports
and mass mandates and a lot of people
just like [ __ ] it i'm not going or
they'll find like a boutique gym and
they'll just take their business over
there that's basically what i did i just
go to this
boutique dojo and i do in my training
there but um yeah i mean if you can help
them bring in more customers and and
it's profitable for them there's
absolutely no way that they would say no
i would just go the freemium route and
say hey look you know we have this
freemium model just try it out you know
like once you reach
5 10 100 users whatever the line in the
sand is you know then you just you know
subscribe and you know you get access to
all the uh
you know like all the good stuff in it
um and that way there's no risk to them
because trust me i know what it's like
to deal with marketing companies that
suck
most of them that i've had experience
with over promise and under deliver and
you get really frustrated whenever
somebody new comes along and they hit
you up with hey i've got this new i have
the best product ever my first reaction
is [ __ ] off right because it's always
you know it's always the same thing so
you've really got to stand out from the
uh crowd on this one and you're doing
something right because you're doing 40
000 a month in revenue like you're
profitable
oh very profitable yeah we have like no
costs
so um blake i don't know if you saw it
earlier but i have a community and we
meet bi-weekly on zoom and we talk
business if you want to get into it
you might want to consider it okay but
all right now check it out
ya
you